let's go next to our caller from the
8:01 area code caller from 8:01
introduce yourself who's this hello
David
yes that's me okay okay cool I did this
is just Blake I'm calling from Salt Lake
City Utah
just chiming in I'm wondering what your
take still on the beta O'Rourke and Ted
Cruz situation
well in terms of who I think is going to
win or what do you mean I mean just I
know bado has been been surging lately
in popularity but you know I'm
cautiously optimistic well listen
yesterday we talked about the new
Quinnipiac poll which has beta O'Rourke
down nine to Ted Cruz in a likely voter
poll a lot of the polls that have been
closed have been registered voter polls
Quinnipiac did a likely voter poll in
beta O'Rourke is down nine so listen
it's an uphill battle I think that it's
a long shot but it's possible it's
possible turnout slow in midterms and
it's going to depend on turnout and it's
going to depend on these last seven
weeks or however it is that we have left
but it's tough to unseat an incumbent
Republican senator in Texas that's what
I've said from the beginning I have some
of the the cautious optimism you have
but it's gonna be a tough one okay all
right yeah just chime in on that
all right you don't vote and you said
you're in Salt Lake City you don't like
vote absentee in Texas or anything like
that
oh no I well I live in a well Texas is
pretty red but I live in a pretty red
state with the LDS Church you know also
I mean we have our local elections I've
been working on here but I've just
that's been getting so much buzz and I
just don't like Ted Cruz and Blake I
take it you're not you live in Salt Lake
City but you're not Mormon right correct
is it comfortable to be a non Mormon in
Salt Lake City I have some friends who
live there who aren't Mormon and they
say increasingly yes if there's just
more and more yeah in Mormon stuff okay
yeah it's kind of an oasis in a way
religious oasis I call it everything's
LDS around you but you're
that body of water that's pretty secular
so what's it like what's appealing about
it why would you end up there instead of
like Austin or Asheville or some other
kind of like you know other city that
maybe is less like centered around one
religion well so far it's just - the
fact that I had lived here I was
military family and all gotcha but I
just haven't left here cool I might one
day all right Blake thank you appreciate
the call you're octo take have a good
one